talking of the voice how long
before you developed the voice or did
you find it pretty quickly uh i started
in the voice six months before we
started filming and then i stayed in it
while we were filming of course which
was really super fun for adam
[Music]
i made him deal with that every [__]
day
uh but you know i'm still doing it
but it actually for me i don't know for
what it's worth ridley shoots fast and
he's got four cameras going
once at any given time if not more so i
thought it was harder to go in and out
of character i thought it was actually
easier to stay in character on set so i
i wish not to sensationalize this thing
but i do wish to uh express gratitude to
my fellow actor that i was on stage with
every day
no okay
[Music]